المناطق الاخرى. المخابرات
العسكرية البريطانية. روسيا
الولايات المتحدة لتوسيع وتعزيز
قدراتها بشكل كبير لمواجهة الجيل
تتلعثم ولا تعرف اداب عام.
واضافت زاخروفا ان ليز حولت
الطاولة فهل يكون هذا الاجتماع
الثلاثي تهديدا للولايات المتحدة
تكبري بعد لتستطيعي وقف لابروف
عن حده. الزمي حدودك. ليز جاهلة
مختلفة تشمل تزويد الدولة
الاوروبية بكميات كبيرة جدا من
السودان لكن هذه مرة في اقليم
النيل الازرق والصراع دائما على
الاسرائيلي. زيارة اسرائيلية
رسمية لرئيس اركان الجيش
منها احد الا في حال اسقاط مشروع
الصدر والحلبوسي والبرزاني. فكيف
في المغرب والطف بنسائه ورجاله
واطفاله وشيوخه. حريق في المغرب
جبناء. وقال المالكي في التسجيل
ان العراق مقبل على حرب طاحنة لا
للجيش الروسي شرق اوكرانيا
لتطويق كل منطقة على حدة ثم تبدأ
سيكون دمارا للعراق وتعجب من
محاولة قتل. هذا ما صرح به مقتدى
قاتل. كما وصف في التسجيل
ميليشيات الحشد الشعبي بانهم
زاخاروفا. ترد على ليز ترانس
الوزيرة البريطانية وتقول لها لم
بها ارتكبها مسؤولون محليون.
صراع عراقي. وصول المالكي للسلطة
حكومتان الجزائرية والايطالية ست
عشرة اتفاقية للتعاون في مجالات
القصر الانجليزي العريق الى حالة
رد. استراتيجية عسكرية جديدة
اصدقائه. وضع لا يحسد عليه
الرئيس الاوكراني الذي كشف عن
تستخدم مرتزقة فاجنر لتعزيز
مواقعها في اوكرانيا. وقعت
عمليات القصف المكثف ثم يكون
الاقتحام والتمشيط والانتقال الى
تتخذا الخطوات اللازمة للايفاء
بشروط انقرة. تناحر قبلي اخر في
ولاءات مسؤولي الصف الاول في
اعلى اجهزة الدولة بمن فيهم اعز
ملكية الارض بين القبائل التي
تصف نفسها بالاصلية والقبائل
العسكرية على الارض عن طريق
الصواريخ التي تفوق سرعتها سرعة
الاسبق الصدر نصح المالكي
بالاعتكاف واعتزال العمل السياسي
بانهاء الفتنة. المالكي اتهم
الصدر في التسجيل المسرب بانه
وثلاثمائة مليون دولار لتطوير
اقمار صناعية هدفها دعم العمليات
وطاجكستان فيها قادة الدول على
تعميق الثقة العسكرية وانضمت
الاحداث والتطورات. الناطقة باسم
الخارجية الروسية ماريا
ستة وتسعين التي ضمت الصين
وروسيا وكازاخستان وكرغيزستان
طهران وموسكو وانقرة على طاولة
واحدة. وعين واشنطن على تلك
القادم من التهديدات الصاروخية
المتقدمة من خلال انفاق مليار
ولا يمكن لاي نظام دفاعي صاروخي
تعقبها ولمواجهتها تتحرك
الامريكية من تنامي تهديدات
الصواريخ الباليستية وصواريخ
او تسليم نفسه ومن يلوذ به من
الفاسدين للجهات القضائية مطالبا
الصدر زعيم الصدري بعد تسريب
مكالمة للمالكي رئيس الوزراء
الامن والمدعية العامة الذين تم
تجميد مهامهما على ذمة التحقيق
قائمة طويلة من المسؤولين الذين
طعنوه في الظهر وعلى رئيس جهاز
بدعوة السعودية للحوار. فهل تخطط
السعودية للتقرب اكثر من طهران
عسكريا الا انها نفذت خمسة
تدريبات عسكرية مشتركة. الغرب
ينطلق منه اي عدوان ضد امننا.
لكن قبل ذلك رئيس الاركان
مناوئة لحلف شمال الاطلسي. ظهرت
نواة الحلف في خماسية شنجهاي عام
الكامل بكل المستويات. معلنا ان
سنستهدف دون تردد للمركز الذي
تنتهي. اذ قال قائد القوة
البحرية الايرانية علي رضا كسيري
مراقب في الجمعية العامة للامم
المتحدة. وبعدها انضمت الهند
وايران وباكستان للمنظمة. وعلى
الرغم ان المنظمة ليست تحالفا
الحرب تضع الرئيس الاوكراني
فولودي ميرزلنسكي امام اختبار
بالنيل الازرق ويرسل كتيبة
عسكرية لضبط الاوضاع في الاقليم.
الكرة الارضية. وتعد اضخم تحالف
سياسي اقليمي في العالم. شنغهاي
الوافدة ومجلس السيادة السوداني
يتحرك لاحتواء العنف القبلي
للتعاون. حلف يجمع معسكر روسيا
والصين. وينظر اليه انه كتلة
على قوتنا في الجزر الثلاث
والخطوط الامامية. الاستنفار
بالدولار مع مرور الوقت. وهناك
اعتبرت واشنطن ان زيارة بوتين
الغاز الطبيعي بصفقات قدرت
باربعة مليارات دولار. اردوجان
من الكرملين الذي قال ان روسيا
وايران ستتخل عن التعامل
الاجتماع كما تقول التقارير
الغربية هو الرد على اجتماعات
الحصول على الضوء الاخضر من
بوتين لاجراء الهجوم. لكن باطن
لطهران تمثل تهديدا بالغا. لكن
تصريحات واشنطن لا تؤخذ على محمل
بيض في الشرق الاوسط فما الذي
يخطط له هذا الثلاثي? اول رد جاء
الجد من قبل بوتين. المهاترة
الكلامية او الحرب الباردة لم
اجتماع ثلاثي بين رؤساء كل من
روسيا وتركيا وايران ظاهر
الاجتماع لمناقشة قرار اردوجان
الهجوم في سوريا ورغبته في
يهدد مجددا بتعطيل انضمام السويد
وفنلندا الى الناتو في حال لم
الصوت بشكل افضل. يبدو انها خطة
جيدة لكن هل تؤتي ثمارها?
المتحدة وبريطانيا واليابان ودول
اخرى مرضت مجددا سلسلة من
نستسلم رغم الصعوبات بسبب
العقوبات الغربية المفروضة علينا
بيئية تستعد لضرب ايران وطهران
ترد بانها لن تتردد في استهداف
التطبيع مع الكيان الاسرائيلي?
تخطيط امريكي. تتزايد المخاوف
الفرض الصوتية الروسية وهي
صواريخ اسرع من الصوت بخمس مرات
ولن يستطيع احد عزل روسيا عن
العالم ولا ارجاع عقارب الساعة
لموسكو للسيطرة على المدن
الاوكرانية. الجزائر توقع
قرية. وفقا لوكالة فهل هذه
الحرائق هي رد الهي يحذر من
الوزراء الروسي لكن الاتحاد عاد
وقال ان العقوبات قد لا تصنع حلا
اي مركز يتم الاعتداء عليها منه.
المالكي يخلق ضجة في العراق
تضعف اقتصاد موسكو لكن هل هي
كذلك حقا? اجتماع ثلاثي رعد.
العقوبات على روسيا. ويقول
مسؤولون غربيون ان هذه العقوبات
الى فيما يخص التنمية الروسية ان
موسكو لن تتراجع او ترتبك وستبحث
كما يعتقد الامريكان
اصبحت عادة لديكم? وهنا جاء الرد
من بوتين سريعا وقال لهم لن
سحريا لكننا ملتزمون بها اذا
فلماذا يتم فرضها يا هؤلاء? هل
منذ عدة تضرر اثره ستة الاف
وستمائة هكتار من الغابات. كما
جرى اجلاء اكثر من الف وثلاثمائة
اسرة موزعة على قرابة عشرين
الاسرائيلي للمغرب تأتي بكارثة
بيئية الهية. اللهم الطف باهلنا
سرعة الصوت باضعاف. فكيف ذلك?
هكذا هي الاستراتيجية الجديدة
جسد الرئيس الاوكراني. وهذه
المرة من اقرب المقربين اليه.
امريكا تحاول ازالة رعبها من
صواريخ روسيا والصين التي تفوق
اشار الى ان هناك تحقيقا في نحو
ستمائة وخمسين حالة خيانة مشتبه
سينتهي هذا الصراع في بلاد
الرافدين? زيارة الشؤم
المتحدة حيث تضم اربع دول نووية.
توالي الخيانات. الخيانة في زمن
هي المنظمة السياسية الاضخم في
العالم. طعنات الظهر لا تتوقع في
وتركيا. قلق متزايد في الولايات
المتحدة من هذا الاجتماع. وهذه
الروسي بوتين سيحط رحاله في
طهران ليجتمع برئيسي ايران
احد ارجاع عقارب ساعتنا الى
الوراء. هكذا اعلنها الرئيس
يصف المنظمة انها ناتو الشرق
الاوسط وتعد اكبر كتلة للولايات
بعدها اليهم اوزباكستان. وفي عام
الفين واربعة اصبحت المنظمة
نحن لن نستسلم. لن نتراجع ولن
نرتبك رغم الصعوبات. ولن يستطيع
وموسكو? انه فعلا لامر عجيب. ابخ
منظمة في العالم. تمثل نصف سكان
هي الحرب يا سادة? وبعد ذلك كله
يا اصدقاء. ها هي ايران ترحب
الاسرائيلي يصرح بانهم يواصلون
الاستعداد للهجوم على ايران. فهل
بنشاط وكفاءة عن حلول جديدة.
الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات
فهل يتم اخمادها? العقوبات
والردود. اعلن الاتحاد الاوروبي
فرض عقوبات على ثمان واربعين
شخصية روسية بين امناء رئيس
والعشائر تتسلح ومقتدى الصدر
يرد. والصراعات تنشب في السودان
اتفاقية مربحة مع ايطاليا. زيارة
اسرائيلية للمغرب تاتي بكارثة